hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
using ips derived cells to generate a
functional human liver through
3d bioprinting i am jennifer woods of
labries and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
ernesto
guerra post doctoral research fellow
at the human genome and stem cell
research center
at the university of sao paulo brazil
ernesto you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone welcome to this uh thermal
official webinar series
my name is dr ernesto gular and i'm i'm
thrilled to be here
today to present you a little bit of the
work that
i've been doing in brazil over the last
five years on stem cell research on
exciting
in stem cell research so first of all
i'd like to thank
uh the invite from thermal fisher
especially
chelsea jennifer and mahlini from
official brazil it's a pleasure to be
here
and so today's talk i'm gonna talk to
you guys
a little bit of how to use ips derived
cells
to generate a fully functional human
river using 3d bioprinting so all of the
work that i've been
going to show you today is published
work
that i'm doing that i developed during
my phd at the university of sao paulo
at the human genome and stem cell
research center
so um first of all
just this is my disclosure that i want
to make sure to pop out
is that i declare that i'm not receiving
any financial or material retribution to
participate in this webinar
so the agenda of this presentation is
divided
basically on three sections so first i'm
going to introduce you
how and why i chose to work with liver
tissue engineering
a little bit of ips cell culture
in ips cell quality control as well
and go to the functional phenotype
differentiation protocols
so this is uh very important because
i think the keynote that i want to show
you guys
is how to properly phenotype your
differentiated stem cells so
i'm going to show you how to
functionally phenotype
epedocytes using 2d differentiation also
endothelial cells
in mesenchymal cells and finally i'm
going to show you how
we derive at this differentiation
protocol
for 3d hepatic differentiation
and finally i'm going to show you a
little bit of the results and
future perspective on the liver tissue
engineering field
so the liver is the larger internal
organ of the body
so it has a lot of function so we all
know that the liver
is responsible for the metabolism of
carbohydrates lipids
nitrogen compounds but also performs
important
function in blood homeostasis such as
hemostasis
and the control of hemodynamics but also
liver performs a very important
function which is a biotransformation so
basically everything that we absorb
in the intestines is transformed in the
liver
to avoid toxic uh effects of the
the molecules that we absorbed so this
is performed majorly by the c
4 5 o is the main
enzyme of this complex that performs
this biotransformation
but also the liver performs an important
role in the cholesterol and lipoprotein
metabolism such as the performs the
fat absorption through the bile
secretion
in the intestine but also in the ldl
metabolism liver performed more than 500
different physiological functions so
basically the liver is a metabolic
hub of our body so in terms of
regeneration the liver is a very
interesting organ
so the liver possessed this amazing
ability to
regenerate itself and this is actually
known back
since the the greek mythology as you can
see here on this picture on top
left there's the prometheus myth in the
greek mythology that
that tell us a story of this titan
called
prometheus that was doomed by the gods
to be attached in the top of a mountain
where every day an evil
will eat part of his liver and the next
day the liver will
grow back and the ego will do that again
over over
throughout the eternity and this ability
to regenerate itself it's
it's quite known uh for for decades
so as you can see here on the bottom
image after a
a partial epidectomy performed in mice
after seven days
the liver goes back to its normal size
and and
also it's a shape as well so this is a
very complex
and timely regulated process of
regeneration
but this is very very interesting in
terms of regenerative medicine
but although the the liver possessed
this amazing ability to regenerate
uh many uh disease can evolve from
chronic exposure to hepatotoxins
so um chronic liver disease affects more
than 60 million people
only in u.s in europe and
the liver cirrhosis which is the
chronic deposition of scar tissue within
the liver
is associated with two percent of global
death burden which is approximately
responsible for
one million deaths a year another
process
uh that is resulted from um
chronic inflammation the liver branch is
called liver statosis
so statosis is the accumulation of fat
within the parenchyma
it was usually associated with alcohol
consumption
but due to this global-wide pandemic of
obesity and diabetes
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease is
estimated to
to affect 20 percent of the global
population
and the fat accumulation within the
liver parenchyma
could lead to what we call nash which is
no alcoholic stealth hepatitis which
is the uh trigger of inflammation
of the liver parenchyma due to this fat
accumulation
on the tissue and this this two process
these two
pathology this roses and steatosis
could lead to the development of cancers
such as hepatocellular carcinoma
which is the fourth leading cause of
death to be among all tumors
and just so you know hepatitis c which
is one of the main
pathogens that could lead to these
excessive inflammation of the liver
parenchyma is estimated to
infect more than 80 million people in
the war on 1.6 million only in brazil
so when the liver reach that
chronic stage it cannot grow back and
cannot regenerate itself
so what can we do to treat patients with
that
condition so basically there's one uh
available option which is
transplantation it could be either
a whole liver transplantation or a
partial liver
transplantation between two live
individuals
so uh although the there were many
uh uh developments in the surgical
field on the organ transplantation
research field
many of the the same challenge that we
faced
back in 1954 where the the first
transplant was performed we still face
it today
which is a donald shortage immune
compatibility issues
rejection and also a lifelong immune
suppressor therapy
so um it is estimated to be
performed around 25 000 liver
transplantations every year in the world
in brazil in 2017 we have more than 5
000 patients in waiting list
at the same year we have almost 3 000
new entries and only perform 2
000 so this data shows us that
there is a huge graph
a gap between the need and the
availability of organs for
transplantation
as you can see here on this um data from
us
where we can see that the gap between uh
organs for transplantation in patients
that need
are still increasing over the over the
years
so we need to do that you do something
for a trash decision
and that's something that i chose to
work
in my scientific career to to develop
new technologies to address this
important issue
so what i'm going to talk to you today
is how to use stem cells to generate
uh functional tissue for transplantation
so basically we're we're using
uh this technology of cell culture that
was
almost two centuries old and applying
new
uh technologies and new exciting
uh discoveries that was performed over
the last few years
that could generate a fully functional
and complex
tissue that could one day met the need
for liver transplantation
so basically liver tissue engineering
and tissue engineering in general
are they are basically depending on two
important factors
so you need we need a scaffold
where the cells will grow onto
and also we need a proper cell source
so we need cells and scaffold to
generate a fully functional
tissue engineering graft so let's talk
to
first on cell source so what are the
cell source that we can use
for living tissue engineering strategies
so there are several options so of
course we have
primary human parasites which are
hepatocytes that are obtained
from disease liver they are highly
functional
because they are obtained from an adult
individual however
they since they are terminally
differentiated cells
they do not proliferate very well in
culture
and they will always generate a troll of
this transplantation so
you you still face the same issues of a
immune rejection in immune suppressor
therapy
but we also have what we call trans
differentiation
protocols which is the
introduction of some few genes that
could transform
perhaps a fibroblast towards an empathic
phenotype such as hepatocytes and this
strains differentiation
protocol it leads to the generation of
very highly functional parasites but
they still have very low proliferative
ability this protocol could generate
autologous transplantation
but as i mentioned before
the liver is the larger internal organ
of the body so we need
a lot of cells to to generate
uh um a very um
important liver function to to to
meet the needs of patients with chronic
liver disease
but uh we do have also stem cells
so we have embryonic stem cells that
once you differentiate the embryonic
stem cells that have this plasticity
that can
generate any cells of your body uh the
cells at the end of the differentiation
they do have a moderate
functionality that means that the the
parasites are differentiated from bionic
stem cells
they are not fully mature they are more
like a fetal phenotype
but the embryonic stem cells are highly
proliferative cells
so we can generate tons of cells within
days
and that's very important for the liver
as i mentioned
however embryonic stem cells will always
generate heterologous transplantation
but we do have ips cells so ips cells
are pluripotent stem cells they are
generated from a process called
reprogramming
which is we take a primary uh cell and
then
transform it back to its po to our poor
important state
where at that time the cells can
differentiate towards any phenotype that
we want so we have the specificity
of the endurance stem cell
there are the differentiated cells from
ips
do also have this moderated
functionality as well
they are highly proliferative and they
can generate autologous transplantation
what does that mean so basically i can
make ips cells
from any individual that we that we that
i want so i can make ipf cells for me
from you any anyone so this is very
interesting because this can generate a
follower's transportation
so uh what we did
uh on in our laboratory is a protocol
that we can take
blood from patients uh is a simple
blood sample collection and then we can
isolate
original glass from that patient and
after the process using uh the
reprogramming factors
call it yamanaka spectre we can generate
ips cell lines from that same individual
and then we established three um
different differentiation protocols
so what are the cells that we need to
generate a liver so basically there are
two
three main cellular phenotypes that we
need
we need the parasites endothelial cells
and mesenchymal cells
so these are the protocols that we
establish in our laboratory so basically
apatocites
go first towards definitive endoderm
then the parabolas and then finally
hepatocytes within
18 days endothelial cells on the other
hand the vascular cells
are derived from mesoderm and then they
were differentiated towards endothelial
progenitor cells where we sort the cells
towards the cd31 positive cells and then
differentiate it
finally towards endothelial cells but we
also need stromal cells
and for that we establish a
mesenchymal differentiation process
where we
go first towards neurographs so
basically the stromal cells that we
are derived here in our work is a more
craniofacial mesenchymal
stem cells so okay
uh we do need we do have now all the
cells that we need to generate a liver
so how can we apply that cells
in a scaffold to generate a fully
functional liver tissue
so in our laboratory we work with
basically two
different technologies we use 3d
bioprinting but we also work with
organoids
so organoids are self-assembled and
tissues that recapitulates early stages
of organogenesis so basically if you
give
the proper factors in the proper
environment to these
three cells that i mentioned in the
previous slide
they uh start spontaneously to organize
and form this tissue that we call
liver organoids that closely resemble
the liver bug
during the early stages of the liver
organic chances
but today i'm going to talk about the 3d
bioprinting
strategy that we recently published so
if you're interested
in getting to know a little bit of the
organized work that i've
developed over the last few years you
can find on this publication
on the top right so let's talk about the
3d bioprinting so
3d bioprinting usually
you use a single cell dispersion
within an hydrogel so the 3d bioprinting
is a process where there is a several
layer deposition
of a biomaterial and this biomaterial is
basically an hydrogel so it's basically
a gel
that could be composed by extracellular
matrix perhaps
and cells so the cells that we
differentiate
so once you uh uh
put this multi-layer structure it can
gives you a 3d shape that you want
so basically all the um
most used 3d bio printing process
use this a single cell dispersion so you
take the cells out of the culture and
then
put it in in an hydrogel however
importantly the parasites which is the
more
important liver parenchyma cells there
are epithelial cells
and as we all know epithelial cells like
to stay in close contact to each other
if they don't do that they could
underwent what we call epithelial
mesenchymal transition
so basically the cells lose the
epithelial phenotype and go towards a
more a mesenchymal
phenotype where the cells can move
throughout the environment
and once they do that usually they lose
uh the phenotype the original phenotype
so this is very critical for the liver
perspective
because if you lose the hepatic the
parasites phenotype
there is no liver function whatsoever
so to address this issue we uh
evaluate the use of what we call
spirits so spirits are a 3d organization
of cells that
closely uh keep keeping in close contact
the epithelial cells so basically all
the hepatocytes are going to be
close to each other in close contact
with each other
and they will eventually retain this
epithelial phenotype
so instead of using uh single cell
dispersion within hydrogel
can we use hepatic steroids and disperse
the
steroids within the hydrogel to make a
more
functional liver tissue so that's
something that we decided to investigate
it and got
very interesting results so let's first
talk about
ips cell and quality control so let's
first check if the ips cells that we
derive it
are indeed ips cells so to do that
first we need to of course check for
chromosomal abnormalities so we perform
what we call mlpa for subcolomeric
regions
and then we evaluate we show that there
is no
trisomy or or any chromosomal
abnormalities whatsoever but we also
check the expression of important
pluripotent markers such as arc 4 and
scc4
on the bottom left here
and also for ips functional
analysis we need to show that the cells
that we generate
have have the ability to differentiate
towards the three germ lines so end of
their mesoderm and actuator
which you can do that by applying a
teratoma and assay as we did
here but we you can also use animal free
method that we can
spontaneously differentiate the cells
and check the expression of important
uh germline markers so
as we as we can show here uh the ips
that we derived
are fully functional ipso lines with no
chromosomal
abnormalities so next we go to
functioning the functional phenotype the
differentiation process that we need to
use
uh in order to generate this liver
tissue so as i mentioned we have the
parasites and euterior cells and
mesenchymal cells so let's
let's see if the hepatocytes that we
differentiated are fully functional
parasites
so first let's let's view the 2d a
parasite differentiation
so as you can see here on the top left
we check the expression of important
hepatic markers such as cytokeratine 18
glycol 6-phosphatase and albumin and
ugta1
throughout the differentiation process
by rtq pcr
and we see the increase of hepatic
differentiation throughout the
differentiation process
at the very end of the differentiation
we stain the cells for full cytometry
for albumin and
gta1 and we can see that almost eighty
percent of our population express
these two important uh hepatic markers
but we also need to see if the parasites
still have the functional ability to
perform
important hepatic functions so on the
bottom image we can see uh
nanase where we put this dye
called icg and this green dye
is transported into the hepatocytes
and then transported back to the
lateral plate of the
parasites which cause what is which is a
process called
basolateral transplantation
transportation so after one hour the
parasites uptake this dye and then after
four hours they release it back to the
media
which shows that the parasites have this
ability to perform viscolateral
transportation
and also we checked the expression by
moon fluorescence
of important hepatic markers such as
c3a4
you can hearing alpha-1 anti-trypsin and
albumin as well
in and and finally we check the
expression of important hepatic
transaminases such as
gsta1 g84 throughout the differentiation
process
and also we checked if there is the uh
uh
the cells that we derive it have the
ability of response to
respond to uh important uh drug inducers
such as
omeprazole and right fantasy so
omeprazole
induced the expression of c1a2
specifically and by fencing and induce
the expression of
c3a4 specifically as you can see here
the treatment of these two drugs
do induce a very specific response of
these two enzymes
okay let's look at the endothelial cells
differentiation
so we stain the cells after sorting them
for cd31 and we show that
the vast majority of the cells are
positive for cd31 and weak adhering
as you can see here on the flow
cytometry chart and also on the moon
fluorescent staining
but the cells that we derive and also
express volvilla brand factor which is
an endothelial
anticoagulant factor and
once we plate the cells on nitrogen and
on a matrix of bed the endothelial cells
spontaneously
start to make blood vessels capillary
vessels as we can see here on on image j
and also the endothelial cells have
these specific ability to uptake
acetylated ldl
as we can see here on letter k
and for um looking at what type of
endothelial cells that we generate
we need to check the expression of
arterial or venous marker
and we observe that um cd31 expression
is is broadly uh being expressed in our
cellular population as we showed in
close circumstance
but we also see the expression of
important uh
arterial markers such as effing b2
and when we treated the cells with a
inflammatory stimuli such as tnf alpha
endothelial cells upregulated icam1
which is recapitulates the neutrophilia
activation of the blood vessel
so that shows that our cells are indeed
responsive to
inflammatory stimuli and finally
let's look at the mesenchymal
differentiation
so we stain our cells at the end of the
differentiation for
mesenchymal markers such as cd90 and
cd73
but we also check the expression of
endothelial and
aquatic markers such as c31 and cd45 so
we show that there's
basically no contamination whatsoever
on the bottom image we can see the
expression of another
stromal marker such as cd104 ono5
i'm sorry and we differentiate the
the mesenchymal cells towards
osteoblasts
um adipoblast and chondroblasts
showing that the mesenchymal cells have
the ability
uh to differentiate towards this uh
stromal phenotypes
as they should because they're
multi-potent stem cells
so on the osteogenic differentiation we
stain the cells for alizarin
red as we can see here for the
chronogenic
differentiation with stain the cells for
all austin blue which
stains are glycosaminoglycans and for a
deeper blast
differentiation we stain the lipid
droplets with all your red
so basically we are showing here that
the mesenchymal cells that we derive it
are indeed multipotent
and the expression of important uh
osteogenic markers such as b glab
quantogenic markers collagen 2 a1 and a
deeper
blast markers such as lpl are indeed
up expressive at the end of this
uh differentiation process
so um finally just let me show you
about the 3d hepatic differentiation
process
that we established in our laboratory
so basically we applied the same recipe
that we use
for 2d hepatic differentiation but
starting off
instead of plated uh 2d plate
uh ips cells but we start us
off as embryonic bodies so the embryonic
bodies are
these um 3d constructs that are derived
when you took the
i when you take the ips and start
spinning them
and we do that by applying uh orbital
shaking throughout the differentiation
process
so basically we use the same recipe and
we check the expression of
important endoderm the fetoblast in
parasite markers
throughout the the differentiation
process we see we
then we observe the same pattern as well
as we observed in the 2d
differentiation process as we can see
also on immune fluorescence staining
here
on the right so uh at the
the very first day the the embryonic
bodies express
pluripotent for protein markers such as
rock 4 and scc4
definitive endoderm markers and day 3
such as cxcr4 or fox a2
and at the end of day 9 or of the
petablos differentiation process the
vast majority of the spheroids that we
derived
express of a feed of protein and meat
and hearing
and at the very end of the 3d
differentiation process
the hepatic steroid is stained positive
for c3a4
albumin alpha-1 antitrypsin cytokeratin
18 and so on
so in order to put this spheroids
in the hydrogel and perform the
extrusion
and layer the position using the 3d
bioprinter we need to
make sure that the spheroids that we
derive it could fit
in the needle so they won't get stuck
when they get shooted
throughout the needle so the mean
diameter of the steroids that we have
was approximately around 200 microns so
that's it's very easy no big problem to
incorporate in the hydrogel and perform
extrusion-based bioprinting
so this is spheroids are actually hollow
structure
and they have this internal basal lamina
where the bacterial cells are deposited
onto
so this is a very interesting uh feature
of epithelial spheroid differentiation
so indeed the cells are in close contact
to each other
so okay we then go to the bioprinting
process
we use a very um
interesting bioprinting process using
this
incredible plus bioprinter we
incorporate the cells divided them
into two groups a single cell printed
group and the spheroid
printed group and then we bioprinted
them
using surgeon base biopainting as we can
see here in the bottom left
and these steroids are um
not damaged throughout the
this extrusion process as we can see
here on the bottom right image
after bioprinting the spirit as well
so let's see how the uh these two
experimental groups perform
over long periods of time in culture
so first we need to check the uh
viability
of the construct so if the cells do
survive over time
and then when we compare a single cell
group
to steroid group we observe that the
viability of
the single cell group decrease over time
significantly
as we can also see on the ldh
expression activity i'm sorry
which is very high at the very first day
of the single cell
uh group and starts to increase back at
the
end of our 18-day period of culture
important uh liver functional markers
such as
the albumin which is being secreted in
the media
also offer one antitrypsin and and
other markers are significantly more
expressive and secreted in the spherical
as we compare to the single cell group
and finally um when we look at the
expression of
important hepatic markers such as
nuclear receptor 1-2 c1a2 c1a1
c3a4 and gsta1 all of these markers are
significantly
more expressive in the spirit group at
the end of our
uh protocol so that shows us
that uh in terms of hepatic function
the spheric group are significantly
superior as we
tested and as compared to the single
cell group
okay but what is going on with the
single cell group
to answer that question we perform a
metabolomic analysis
so we took the supernatant of the
culture and analyzed every metabolites
on the media
and we observed on this principal
component analysis
of very distinguished pattern between uh
single cell group and spheric group
and when we look at in uh the
gos of this analysis we observe that
urea and amino acids metabolism
are the main different differently
observed metabolites in the media
so basically the spirit group has a lot
of
amino acids that are being generated in
the culture
so why are these amino acids being
generated in the culture
so to answer that question we perform
a proteomic analysis we look
at the differently expressed proteins
on these two groups and we observe that
the
in most enriched pathways are
associated with protein metabolism
so basically what we show here is
that the uh on the single cell group
they are starting to the cells are
starting to break down proteins in order
to generate energy
so this is this is not a very uh good
feature because
as we all know uh the first uh option to
generate
uh energy from is sugar and the second
one is lipids and finally if you do not
have any more options
you start to break down proteins in
order to generate energy so that
shows us that the single cell the single
cells printed
in within these hydrogels are
in a severe stress environment and
they're starting to die
and we check the expression of important
epithelial mesenchymal markers
and to see if there is any uh emt
epithelial mesenchymal transition
going on and we observe that the
vimenting expression is significantly
[Music]
being overexpressed in the single cell
group and by mentioning the mesenchymal
marker
and also we test the expression of
important
uh epithelial caterins
such as cdh1 and cdh2 and we observe
that in on spheroid group
uh there we can see uh significant
increased expression of these two
epithelial markers and we test the
expression of
male 2 so neo2 is a transcription factor
involved in the epithelial mesenchymal
transition
and we see that the single cell group do
express more of
this gene so combining all this
evidence we show that on the single cell
group
we start the cells are starting to die
they are breaking down proteins and they
are indeed transforming
um towards a more mesenchymal
non-functional
phenotype so in summary
we establish a multi-differentiation
process from the same from the same
patient
using a simple blood sample collection
we combined that with a modern
3d bioprinting process and then we
generate
a more mature stable liver
tissue that could one day be used as a
graft for
organ transportation replacement this
organ
is indeed autologous to the original
patient and this whole process
today took us take us around 90 days
from the blood collection to the final
maturation of the bioprinting
liver so um
in terms of future perspective in the
bioprinting
field i consider that the development
and the testing of bio-link formuli that
uses liver specific
extracellular matrix proteins are very
very important so we need to create the
proper liver environment for the cells
to perform as they should and also we
need to increase
cellularity which is the density of the
cells that we use
in the bioprinting strategies such as we
can also apply
new methodologies that have been
developed or developed over the last few
years
that do not use actually hydrogels so
they they indeed
generate a very high cellular uh
cellularity tissue this technologies
have been developed by several groups
and one very interesting
recently published uh paper described
this
this new methodology called sacrificial
writing to functional tissue
it's a very interesting methodology that
we i believe
that could be the next um
strategy for deriving liver tissues
but we also need to increase liver
cellular phenotype diversity
the liver is not only composed by
hepatocytes endothelial cells and
stromal cells
the liver also has cholegiocites copper
cells and so on
many many other cellular phenotypes
and as we increase this uh cellular
divert diversity
we should increase liver functionality
and finally we need to increase
structural complexity and size
because we need a very
functional tissue but also large tissue
to
perform the hepatic function that the
patients with chronic liver disease
needed
so uh at this point i just would like to
thank you
very much for your attention of course
uh this the work that i presented here
was not certainly
performed by me it's a it's a teamwork
especially i would like to thank uh
professor mayana zacz which is uh are
the pi of our laboratory but also
professor siobhan ohio professor peter
lelkash from temple university
our long-time collaborator but also i'd
like to extend my knowledge to uh dr
louise caitis and kaiki tell us of our
liver tissue engineering team and also
our colleagues from
the institute of bioscience and the
medical school of the university of sao
paulo
and also i would like to thank our
financial support for
several institutions that make this made
this work possible
at the very beginning so thank you very
much for your time
and if you want to contact me directly
you can just
scan this qr code and then contact me
throughout all my social
media links that you can see that you
you'll find
on this qr code scan thank you very much
for your time in consideration
thank you ernesto for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left
of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
let's see what bio ink did you use to
create the 3d model
thanks for your question um so for this
work
specifically we use a very well known
and standard bioinformalite that is
composed by
alginate alginate is a
sugar polymer that is obtained in algae
and it's very well standard used in
biopic but you can use
any hydrogel or bioink formula that you
want
okay great thank you ernesto our next
question here is
how many spheroids can be printed per
well from one syringe
well that will depend on the size
of the well because for
3d differentiation of the parasites the
size and the quantity of the cells will
determine
the final yield of steroids so
um basically on a six-well plate you
generate at around 50-100 steroids
but it depends on the protocol of the
rotation that you use
the quantity of the cells per well and
uh in terms of bioprinting this number
only depends actually on the diameter of
the final spirits
if the diameter is compatible with
extrusion procedure
and the quantity of the the spirit that
you want to put the density of the
spirits that you want to put that you
can change and variety according your
protocol
thank you ernesto our next question
you mentioned about the regeneration of
liver as far as i know liver is an
asymmetrical organ
can all parts of the liver give rise to
a whole liver
and does it gain its its symmetry i'm
sorry does it gain its asymmetry after
regeneration
so yeah i mentioned that the liver grows
back to its normal size especially
weight and in terms of shape and
symmetry
because of the diaphragm that is placed
right in top of the liver
like uh putting a little pressure on the
liver
so it gains a little the shape of the
original
organ it does not necessarily uh
thoroughly recapitulate the shape and
the symmetry of the original liver
but it gains a little very close uh
shape as the original organ yeah
okay thank you ernesto and our next
question here
is let's see
this person has a question regarding the
spheroid printing approach
have you tried or considered printing
hetero heterospheroids
seeing how you produce hollow
monosteroids
yeah this is a very good question and
suggestion actually
yes we are now working with combining
um uh parasites and european cells into
these 3d aggregates
that we call spirits and as for the
second
part um the steroids they
uh the panic spirits they are
spontaneously
hollow structured so we do not have to
do anything they
spontaneously form this internal basal
lamina
why because basically there are exterior
cells
so they need to one make their own basal
lamina and
attach to each other so every
almost every epithelial tissue that
grows in 3d
we'll eventually do this they from this
hollow shape
thank you ernesto our next question
this person says you have a superb
presentation
and how can this be taken to
translational research
well that's a very good question um
first of all
we need to um still feel some gaps on
this technology so one is
scalability so we need a lot of cells so
when we need a lot
to test a lot of methodology to gain
scale
so to produce more cells to um
diminish the cost of the end of the the
protocol so this is this is very complex
so
but one thing that i um very interested
in is to increase the functionality
and of the construct so basically the
liver is not composed only by three
phenotypes so these are the main
phenotypes of the liver but we still
have chlorangiocytes copper cells
steroid cells so there are a lot of
different uh cellular phenotypes so i
think in increasing the diversity of the
cell
phenotype could play a major role in
increasing the functionality
so yeah so there's a lot to do in terms
of translation so
scalability i think is the main
technological issue
in terms of potential and translate
research
great thank you and we have another
question
can you speak to the necessity or
advantage to 3d printing
versus aggregation strategies
so um the advantage of using 3d
bioprinting
as compared to spontaneous aggregates or
organoids or whatsoever
is that you can create your own shape as
you want
so you can print the shape of the
structure the final t-shirt final graph
the way that you want so let's say in
the future you can take our mri
email scan of your body and then plot it
in a computer matter and
breathe the tissue that you want the
shape the dimensions that you want
this could be very tricky in aggregation
so
this is one advantage and the second one
is that hardware
of the 3d bioprinting uh process
it's it's quite easy to scale to gain
skill
so you can build bigger machines you can
build several machines you can automate
the whole process
so this is a very important intense in
terms of
uh homogeneity of the results that you
gain at the end of the different
of the process but but again aggregation
organoids are very interesting
strategies as well and they can easily
be used simultaneously depends on the
uh the patient and the need for it
great thank you so much we have another
question here
can the metabolic degradation of amino
acids be directed toward glycolytic
degradation and would this make the
organ more resistant
this is a good question i don't have any
do it
to answer uh more uh precisely your
question but
it's a good idea it could be tested
uh but what we show in our work is that
what is going on at that moment
on the construct so if we managed to
shift the metabolism yeah sure that
would be terrific and this could
increase the resistance of the
constructs over time
so out of this was performed of course
in vitro so we need to check to test if
uh this methodic shift of course is also
in uh in vitro uh testing uh setup as
well
indivo sorry
that's okay thank you again ernesto our
next question
how scalable are the use of ips derived
hepatic spheroids for a clinical trial
setup
yeah that's that's uh very interesting
so um in terms of
care and capability as i mentioned is an
important issue
uh all of this technology
gain in scale because the hardware the
knowledge
for it is already there so you only need
to adapt
the machines and uh anyway so
this is it's easy it's not impossible
it's very it's very
uh possible to do that in the near
future
but we um it gains a lot in
costs so it's the protocol starts to get
very expensive so we've been
properly investments in development in
the hardware
it's uh it's very likely to this to be
extremely acceptable for a clinical
setup
thank you ernesto we've got a couple
more questions coming in here
do ibs have tumor let's see
tumerogenicity
yes so one of the main issues
with uh using uh open stem cell derived
cells in any clinical approach
is there is the possibility of any
residual pluripotent stem cells in your
culture in your final product
and that could indeed lead to the
development of some
types of cancer that are known as
teratomas
so one way to avoid that uh actually
there's no one way there's several ways
that you can avoid that and
properly test that uh first of all
pollen control so you you can scan your
final
differentiation culture for any residual
critical potency
and also there are some protocols that
you can specifically
eliminate all the residual pluripotents
of your culture so
reducing the risk of any formation
of era thomas to zero so yes this is one
issue and this can be easily addressed
by problem
sensory fabric hello control
thank you ernesto we've got more
questions coming in
are spheroids genetically and
phenotypically stable
yes they're actually much more stable
as compared to the 2d differentiation
um because they as i said in the
presentation they
are um in close contact to each other so
they are
phenotypically very stable because they
do not move to move around so they
don't need to perform or do not perform
emt if you're in the zinc
transition and in terms of uh genetic
stability
yes they are also genetically stable as
compared to a
primary human parasites or even a
root tissue as well
thank you ernesto our next question is
do we already have products on the
market
products to differentiate the other
cells needed to manufacture the liver
yes there are several products in the
market
there are several companies that sell
both
research grade reagents for
produce and differentiate cells for that
thermofisher is one of the leading
companies on that but you also have a
gmp
quality products as well in the markets
in terms of a clinical setup this is
very important so these gmp materials
are already available in the markets
great thank you ernesto our next
question is
when cells are converted to endothelial
cells have you checked whether these
cells can interact with parasites
since parasites are the only cells which
interact with endothelial cells
well i never checked that this is a very
interesting question
uh especially because we have
mesenchymal cells
in close proximity to endothelial cells
it might also be possible to see some
phenotype conversion of those cells to a
more
parasite-like phenotype and this
is closely linked to this previously
question that i mentioned that if you
increase
the diversity of the cell and phenotype
in the final liberal construct i
strongly believe that we will increase
the functionality of the final product
so yes there's this third sets are
another cells that we need to add
to this contrast constructs so
yeah there's something to work with
i've got a time for i've got time for a
few more questions here
i understand the need for cellular
diversity in replicating
a liver as functional as possible with
coop for cells etc
is the goal to give a fully functional
liver to a patient or give them a piece
of functional
at peace function enough so their bodies
finish the growth process
on that piece yes
yeah it depends on the need right in
terms of
uh size and function so if you have a
patient that have a very uh
sincere chronic liver disease so this
patient will probably need a lot of
liver
replacement function so yes but there
are some other
diseases and conditions that i did not
mention that actually do not need a
fully
uh uh functional river graph or even a
real size with a graph
let's say uh in their errors of
metabolism
so this is a set of genetic diseases
that usually wear a pediatric disease
so the patients usually have a mutation
on one enzyme
and that enzyme deficit could lead to a
severe uh let's say
liver uh impairment so if you have a
tiny piece of the river
that can provide this uh one enzyme need
uh you probably will get a good result
and do not have to necessarily
transplant a full
size and functional liver graft so this
is something to
to test and i think that makes sense
we have time for one more question if
you transplant the ips
derived liver graft back to the original
cell donor
what are the odds of a potential tissue
rejection
well the odds are very low because in
terms of hiv
matching they are identical some in
terms of cellular rejection
close to zero but of course this need to
be tested but there are some results
that shows that in terms of
mitochondrial dna the ipad cells can
can in some ways uh show differences
from uh the original donut but
again this needs to be tested in terms
of hla
i think the ads and cellular rejection i
think the odds are very very low
close to zero but again this needs to be
tested
thank you ernesto do you have any final
comments for our audience today
no i appreciate a lot uh first of all
the invite from time official to
participate in this webinar
series and i appreciate also the
comments and
the questions they were very good
questions and very good comments
i have nothing to say anymore so thank
you very much for your time and the
opportunity to speak to you today
and thank you again ernesto for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye